well maybe cuz I know I would have
pressed everything if you told me I had
to get in there I would have pressed
whatever I had to press representative
Jamal Bowman Democrat from New York was
caught on camera pulling the cannon fire
alarm ahead ahead of his this motion to
adjourn the vote as Democrats tried to
delay the CR vote multiple sources tell
me we have reached out to him for
comment we haven't reviewed the footage
ourselves well
hallelu Olivia you are in luck lady
because there are cameras at the capital
and hot diggity dog they took a picture
of Jamal Bowman pulling the fire alarm
he didn't know what he was he had no
idea what he was doing it was a red
thing and it said fire alarm on it was
some sort of something or other
Connor yeah we're going to the view
ladies and gentlemen here is whoopy
Goldberg explaining that she would have
done the same thing if you're not
sure then put it up for find out what it
was as opposed to just saying you know
you did this to do that because when you
people pull stunts I tend to think that
they they may be more full of it than
than his you know people who pull this
kind of stunt who say and you only have
3 minutes to read it I kind of think oh
all right well maybe cuz I know I would
have pressed everything if you told me I
had to get in there I would have pressed
whatever I had to press get the door to
open cuz I knew you would expect me not
to be there to vote so you don't know
we'll be right back who
be you you you d
um even if everything you just said
there is true and I think we can mostly
agree that they Rush these things
through and nobody reads them and Nancy
Pelosi remember Nancy Pelosi we have to
pass the bill so we can find out what's
in it even if all of that was true a
fire alarm doesn't open a door there's
no connection there's no electronic
connection between the fire alarm and
the door I would have been pulling
everything to open that door all right
none of those things work here's sunny
hustin and I I don't want to call it a
stunt yet there's going to be an
investig ation I know Jamal and so again
I'm a little biased but the doors that
are normally open so that he could get
to the chambers to read Were Somehow
miraculously closed how did that happen
and so yes sometimes you're freaking out
and you're in an elevator you're
pressing all the butt you were saying it
goes to them not having the time I've
been going to elevators probably about
47 years of my life okay I have never
accidentally you actually you might
press the wrong floor every now and
again you know I travel a lot sometimes
I'm in hotels different hotels different
nights and sometimes I'm like I'm on the
third floor and actually the night
before I was on the fourth floor that
seems legit how often are you just
pressing buttons like a crazy person
figuring out pulling levers and pressing
butt these people are all completely
it's not that they're bananas though
right like they're not ban they're doing
exactly what they are supposed to be
doing and the in some ways the worst
case uh the worst example of someone
doing exactly what they're supposed to
be doing is the pet conservative on the
view of course I'm talking to Alyssa
Farah they give her a cookie they pat
her on the head they'll turn on her and
Destroy her but listen to the way she
frames the guy who pulled the fire alarm
it's not nobody's alleging it nobody's
something like a fire alarm no none of
that is true a man pulled the fire alarm
we have it on photo photographic
evidence of it he admits it but listen
to how she frames it to vote on a
multi-trillion dollar bill that they
didn't have time to read which brings us
to my buddy Jamal Bowman all right
so okay so Democratic House member uh
allegedly pulled a fire alarm um he
claims that it was because he was trying
to get to the house floor I it see the
video seems to or pictures suggest
otherwise I think it was because the CR
came out and he wanted more time to read
the bill but rather again than Congress
passing a bill that would allow for him
to have more time to read it he
literally pulled the fire alarm it'd be
like if I was like didn't like the next
topic and I pulled the fire alarm and
ran out we just can't do that absolutely
ridiculous though is that there's magga
Republicans that are somehow equating
this guy doing this infantile stunt
with January 6th to my knowledge nobody
died because this guy pulled that stunt
to my knowledge nobody was bleeding
nobody was attacked because of this
stunt you know I'm really trying to
reach my higher self these days I'm a
father now I'm trying to I'm trying to
get to a deeper spiritual place so I'm
not going to talk about Anna Naro today
okay I'm not going to do it but Alyssa
you see what she did there it's like
everything at once they they
intentionally on one hand she's saying
allegedly it was done and then she
explains that he completely did it the
language they use language in a weird
way to keep everybody
stupid